I've made some adjustments to the London
50 trading model. If you think I'm an
idiot for having this many trades, stick
around for the video. At the end of it,
you're going to be convinced to try this
model. What's going on, guys? Mr. Zinc
here. If you want to go and rewatch the
original London 50 trading model video,
I'll drop the link to that right here,
and then you can come back to this one
for the changes. I've made three changes
to the strategy that have helped me net
$10,700 in the past two trading days,
albeit quite a few trades placed.
This is acquired from several months of
back testing that told me the data told
me that we needed to make these changes.
The first one being we are no longer
using previous days 50 for bias. We used
to use that previous days 50 to assess
whether we were bullish or bearish until
the following day. Again, several months
of back testing have told me that we are
no longer needing this tool. We no
longer need to use previous days 50 for
the bias. I'm using the week of August
4th to August 8th for back testing
purposes. If you want to follow along on
your trading view, go for it. So, Monday
into Tuesday, our previous day's 50
drawn in. All right, price opened over
previous days 50. We have a bullish
bias. We're looking for long setups. But
wait a minute, price on Tuesday did
nothing but go to the downside. All
right, maybe that's just a fluke. Let's
draw uh Tuesday into Wednesday.
All right, same thing. Price opened
underneath the previous day's 50. We
have a bearish bias. We have a gap down
there. Maybe we go and fill that gap.
Nope. Price for Wednesday went up the
entire day. I think you're getting the
picture here. We are no longer using
that previous day's 50 to tell us what
the bias is for the day. Rather, what
we're doing with that previous day's 50,
we're still drawing it in every day.
We're using it for reactions. We're
using it for levels because the levels
are still significant. Previous day's
high, previous days low, previous days
50.
Going over Thursday, August 7th, and I
actually trade this one yesterday. This
is one of the pictures on here. 50
trades. Good lord. We had six trades
alone at that previous day's high. We
averaged into some of those trades. So
that six trades ended up turning into
somewhere between 10 to 12 trades. All
with 1 to 2 M and Q again up to 4 to 8 M
and Q total lots.
We had six reactions. All six printed
beautiful 20 to 30 point bounces or
rejections. In this case,
we're still using that previous day's
50, but no longer using it for the bias.
Change number two. We do not, and I
repeat, we do not use the opening
15-minute candle anymore. The reason
being, data has told me that 45% of the
losses associated with this trading
model have come from that single candle,
that single 15-minute opening candle.
That's a data point that I could not
ignore. I may not have believed at
first, but when I really thought about
it, yeah, most of those losses we take
come from that opening 15-minute candle.
It almost always hits the London 50,
London high, London low. On the opening
15 minute, you have a trade that you can
take a reaction on. Friday's case, we
have our London high, London low. Okay,
let's say, let's say I wanted to take a
rejection there. Price hit that level. I
could have taken a rejection and then it
just continue to slice right through it.
That's a stop loss there as the stop
loss is a 15-minute candle closure over
or under the level that we're taking.
Given that we have a 15-minute stop
loss, this opening 15-minute candle
could have a 50 point stop. It could
have a 10-point stop, it could have a
100 point stop. The 15-minute candle is
exciting. The opening 15-minute candle
is exciting to trade because you have
everyone overnight that wants to get
into the market. You have volatility
with that candle, especially on Mondays
where you have everyone eager to trade
for Sunday, Saturday. they want to get
back in the market and the Monday
opening candle is anywhere from 50 to
150 points. So that change had to
happen. Most of our losses, not most of
them, 45% of our losses, so just under
half
essentially been wiped out by avoiding
that 15-minute candle. So if you want to
start your trading day at 9:45, go for
it. And the last adjustment for the
video, three reactions at one level
invalidates that level directionally.
I'm going to use Thursday, August 7th,
to review this. We have our London 50
drawn in. We have our previous days 50
drawn in again for previous days 50.
We're using that just for level
reactions. No longer using it for the
bias. And then we are no longer trading
that opening 15-minute candle. I did
take one loss here, trading a move over
London high, and then immediately waited
for price to come back down to the
London 50. This new rule
is three taps. So, we have our first tap
at 10:15, second tap at 10:30. Third tap
at 10:45. I'm going to go down to the
five minute time frame. So, we can see
just how many taps were at this level.
Our London 50 is this middle line. We
had one, two, three, four taps.
After that third one, no longer looking
to go long off that level.
That's the directional part of this
strategy or of this change.
If I'm looking for bounces off of London
50, three taps is all I get. So, I look
one tap upside, two tap upside, third
tap upside. Fourth tap, no longer
looking to go long. Now that price has
flipped below London 50, I'm looking to
go short. One tap to the upside, short.
Second tap to the upside, short. And
then price proceeded down to previous
days high along with London low. I'm
taking another set of reactions at those
levels. So first one, London low,
previous day's high. I can take a long
there. Price bounced. Second one, price
bounced again. Third one again on the
five minute. There were several
reactions here. I'm not going to go and
adjust it again.
Third tap, long again.
No longer looking to go long. Fourth one
fell right through. Now we're looking to
take rejections back down. First
rejection,
hit it perfectly. Another 100 point
drop. Second one hit it perfectly again.
Another 100 point drop. And then price
continued down for the day. I'm not
trading the closing 15-minute candle
either. You can do it for some
strategies, some models, but I prefer
not to touch it. Three taps is all you
get at each level. anything after that
third tap. And this goes for seeing it
happen on the five minute time frame,
seeing it happen on the three minute
time frame.
If you're watching it real time and
you're seeing price repeatedly hit the
level, you're counting in your head.
One, two, three. Okay, that's three
taps. I'm no longer taking that to the
upside or downside.
Make sure that you keep track of the
taps.
Anything over four, anything over three,
no longer using it. three and above.
Now, if you've made it to this point in
the video, congratulations because you
just unlocked the most important add-on
that we've made to the trading model,
directional bias.
This states that 80% of the time price
is trending in one direction, it will
continue to trend in that direction.
Only 20% of the time will price reverse
on itself. If we have an uptrend,
there's an 80% chance that that uptrend
will continue for the entire trading day
all the way up until that 800 PM close.
Monday, for example, rather than trying
to be a top collar and be in disbelief
that price is continuing to push up,
switch that bias and look for pullbacks
to go long into. This is exactly what I
did on Monday. I made about $800 per
account. So, $4,000
on those five XFAS simply waiting for a
pullback to get into. I entered on this
10:30 candle. We had a 70cent
correction. I held that trade for about
an hour and then we had a dollar
continuation back to the upside and
ended up making a new high day and to
close.
Stop trying to call tops and bottoms.
You should understand the statistic
states that you are going to be losing
80% of the time if all you're looking
for is trying to call that top or call
that bottom for the big gain on the day.
Wait for a pullback to re-enter that
trend.
This data also states that one out of
every five trading days is going to have
a reversal. That's just statistics.
You're not going to have a 100% win rate
with a strategy. You're not going to
have 100% win rate with anything.
Thursday was that 20% chance. However,
if you notice, Thursday trended down all
the way until 2:30. So, you had four and
a half hours, five and a half hours of
trading in that trend where you waited
for pullbacks back to the upside and
then got back into the trend. You also
had six reactions at the London 50 that
you could have traded. You had six
reactions at previous days high along
with London low. And then you had
another six reactions at that psych
level 23,400
on NQ.
Beautiful setup for Thursday. That's why
I had so many trades. And then the same
thing for Friday. We had trend all day
today.
Yes, we had some dips, but those dips
are where you re-enter. Now, I had 84
trades today. A little embarrassed to
say. So, they were not large trades.
They were 1 to 2 MNQ. And if you look at
these candles, especially the ones that
we had after 130, the largest candle we
got was maybe 30 points. All these
candles,
6 cents, 11 cents, 8 cents, 7 cents, 2
cents, and this is an hour and 15
minutes worth of trading right here.
They were small wins, but those wins
added up and that has netted me $10,700
for this week. Along with these three
changes, knowing the directional bias,
this trading strategy likely has an 82%
win rate. Now, this is just for the
week. I can't wait to start back testing
this again. Any questions that you guys
have, drop them in the comments. If
you're annoyed with how many trades I
took, thinking that I'm an idiot, so be
it. Try out the concepts that I proved
in this video because they work
incredibly well. This is probably the
simplest trading strategy you're going
to use. Try it out for a week. Let me
know how you like it. Drop a like on the
video. Subscribe. Let me know what you
want to see for next video. I'll see you
guys later. Peace out.